ya hemos hecho varios vídeos sobre las
reglas de la cadena en donde vemos
muchos ejemplos sobre el tema pero lo
que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
enfocarnos en los malentendidos clave
que se cometen a menudo y de hecho hemos
sacado estos malentendidos de los amigos
que han presentado las pruebas de app
del college board así que imagina que
queremos tomar la derivada de esta
siguiente función de la función
logaritmo natural del seno de x la
derivada con respecto a x del logaritmo
natural del seno de x
entonces el primer malentendido clave
que vamos a tratar y que puedes tener es
cuando trabajas con funciones
trascendentales y decir funciones
trascendentales es una forma elegante de
llamar a funciones como las
trigonométricas o las funciones
logarítmicas etcétera que por definición
no usan las típicas operaciones
algebraicas así que cuando ves funciones
trascendentales como éstas o
composiciones de estas entonces muchas
personas se confunden y piensan que esto
es una multiplicación de funciones así
que en un principio cuando ves esto
piensas que esto es exactamente lo mismo
que déjame escribirlo aquí la derivada
con respecto a x del lugar y tmo natural
de x esto que multiplica al seno de x y
puedes ver que en esta forma como están
escritas se ven muy similares
este es el producto de dos funciones
observan puedes ver el logaritmo natural
de x como efe de x y al seno de x como x
y ahora sí aquí puedes ver cómo es el
producto de efe y de gm y por lo tanto
tendremos que usar la regla del producto
para resolver esta derivada déjame
escribirlo en este caso usamos la regla
del producto pero ten cuidado aquí
tenemos la composición de funciones en
esta ocasión tenemos a efe deje de x
porque si llamamos a gd x al seno de x
entonces aquí tendríamos la función f
que es el logaritmo natural aplicado al
seno de x es decir aplicado a gtx
observamos el logaritmo natural del seno
de x es lo mismo que efe dgp de x así
que si alguien te pregunta cuánto es
fx bueno ese sí es el logaritmo natural
de x pero aquí tenemos el logaritmo
natural de gd x el logaritmo natural del
seno de x bien entonces aquí está la
clave ten cuidado cuando tengas una
composición de funciones trascendente
usa la regla de la cadena si es que la
tienes
ojo no la regla del producto y de hecho
ten cuidado más porque puede existir en
alguna ocasión que tengas una
combinación del producto de una
composición de funciones en cuyo caso
será un poco más laberíntico y la
resolución así que pon mucha atención de
que no estás trabajando con una
composición de funciones bien ahora
vamos a hablar del siguiente
malentendido clave que se puede tener y
es que aunque sepas que tienes que usar
la regla de la cadena en algún punto no
sepas cómo terminarla o más bien hace
falta determinar la derivada es más
déjame usar el mismo ejemplo para que
veas a lo que me refiero la regla de la
cadena de aquí nos dice lo siguiente
mira primero tenemos que tomar la
derivada de la función exterior con
respecto a la función interior y bueno
la derivada del logaritmo natural de x
es 1 / x 0
no queremos la derivada del logaritmo
natural de x con respecto a x queremos
esa derivada con respecto a ge de x por
lo tanto no vamos a tomarnos como
entrada a x y vamos a poner como entrada
a gd x entonces en lugar de poner uno
entre x vamos a poner uno entre g de x
pero como ya sabemos que gdx es el seno
de x bueno pues esto es igual a 1 entre
el seno de x ahora el malentendido clave
que te quiero decir es parar justo aquí
y no terminar la derivada es decir hacer
bien la primera parte de la derivada y
olvidar la segunda parte observa aquí
todavía tenemos que tomar esto y
multiplicarlo por g prima de x es más
déjame escribir que prima de x bueno
quiero la derivada del seno de x con
respecto a x lo cual sabemos que es el
coseno de x entonces en este ejemplo de
aquí la derivada completa va a ser bueno
primero tengo esta parte que es uno
entre el seno de x por la segunda parte
que es el
tx así que vamos a escribirlo 1 / seno
de x por el co seno de x
así que una vez más para estar seguros
de que no estás cometiendo uno de los
malentendidos claves es más déjame hacer
una caja para poner la respuesta
correcta y tener todo mucho más limpio
para no cometer uno de estos
malentendidos claves primero tienes que
fijarte si tienes una composición de
funciones ojo si tenemos una composición
de funciones entonces no vamos a usar el
producto de funciones en este caso no
tenemos el logaritmo natural de x por el
seno de x tenemos al logaritmo del seno
de x y después cuando aplicas la regla
de la cadena ya que existe la derivada
de la función exterior con respecto a la
función interior es decir la derivada
del logaritmo natural de x con respecto
al seno de x ahora me recuerda a
multiplicar esto mismo por la derivada
de la función interior con respecto a x
así que no olvides la derivada de la
función interior bien espero que hasta
aquí vayamos bien porque quiero ver un
tercer típico malentendido y es
es que en lugar de aplicar la regla de
la cadena como está escrita aquí te
tomas a la derivada de la función
exterior con respecto a la derivada de
la función interior por ejemplo cometes
el error de tomarte efe prima de g prima
de x que en este caso f prima de x ya
sabemos es 1 / x pero ahora la derivada
de gx es el coseno de x ya lo vimos
hasta aquí entonces te quedaría la
derivada de la función exterior con
respecto a la derivada de la función
interior lo cual está mal y pondrías uno
entre el coseno de x y ten mucho cuidado
de que no lo estás haciendo mal debe
quedarte la derivada de la función
exterior con respecto a la función
interior
no con respecto a la derivada de la
función interior y recuerda después
multiplicarlo por la derivada de la
función interior así que espero que todo
esto te ayude ahora bien si todo esto te
es desconocido te encargo que veas la
serie entera sobre la introducción a la
regla de la cadena
en la can academia este vídeo va a
formar parte del tema pero aquí vamos a
estar solamente enfocados en los
malentendidos de la regla de la cadena y
no en explicar cómo funciona así que ya
sabes primero no uses la regla del
producto después no te quedes con la
regla de la cadena la mitad y por último
no evalúes efe prima de g prima de x
estos tres son los malentendidos típicos
la regla de la cadena así que ten
cuidado